camp without fear ball listen listen I
don't know I felt like I out and
everybody knew that you were gonna do it
but now it's official and you did it
thank you so much I am so excited I
honestly I can't believe that I'm here I
mean I'm this girl from Australia who
actually wildlife and I got to learn how
to dance
and now I'm here and it's all things
honestly to Derek for always believing
me in me and just staying strong and I'm
so so lucky so thank you for everything
for us
I gotta ask the important question you
get home you walk through the door
you're holding your mirror ball where
does it go in your house where you're
putting it we were talking about this
actually I said you had a good idea I
think it should go in the zoo in the
middle of the crocodile like chamber so
which is in the middle the foot in the
middle of the what do you call it the
croc pond we got baa there you go come
on Darrin croc bond and they're just
surrounded by it so it's like there it
is guys the Crocs just guarding it I
didn't do Gaza I think it it worked now
let me ask you this since you've been on
Dancing with the Stars have like how are
the offers been from Hollywood how does
your relationship change with respect to
Hollywood and your opportunities here
versus going home to Australia is that
gonna shift at all oh well you know I'm
really excited because I would love to
continue to spread my message on many
different platforms and I'm excited to
see what's yet to come in my future but
home will always be Australia and
honestly I cannot wait to get back to
all of my animals then to just go and
lay under the trees with my snake and my
rhinos it'll be so nice
Matheson's day that's something you hear
every day now can we expect anything
else in the u.s. that you might appear
on any other offers coming your way you
know there's there's a few different
things that I would love to be a part of
and I'm just I'm really excited to see
what's on the horizon